so all politicians have people who
imitate them who do impressions of them
Kamal Harris is one of the few who
really doesn't and that's because Kamal
Harris herself is doing a Kamala Harris
impression there is no actual Kamala
Harris and so it's it's kind of a meta
question it's very tough it's very
difficult to pull off the rambling
incompetence and the cackling but we
have searched the entire continental
United States for someone who can do it
and we have found one watch this
before we get to all that I am Kamala
Harris my name is Vice President Kamala
Harris first woman VP
my pronouns are she and her I am a woman
sitting at the table wearing a blue suit
my pronouns are she and her
FIFA faux fum
I'm wearing a blue suit
one of many my pants are Old Navy
and school buses are yellow because
think about it yellow school buses are
our nation's largest form of mass
transit
yeah largest form of mass transit
so clearly the University of New star's
name is Este has the kind of faintly
hallucinogenic quality down but it's the
cackle
that she really nailed she joins us now
St thank you so much for coming on
um the cackle can you just do that again
I think you perfected it
hello America
[Laughter]
yeah what I don't know I don't know if
yeah hey I don't know if you live with
others roommate spouse friends whatever
when you do that cackle around other
people like how do they respond
uh sometimes they leave the room it
really depends on what what team they're
playing for but for the most part it
turns heads for sure I think I think I
fine-tuned it down to get it to sound
just like her just for masochistic
reasons can you do one more time
[Laughter]
so perfect so the state of the Union's
coming up next next week do you have a
preview for us
well Tucker I really want to make sure
that we can Galvanize our time and when
we get there we want to lead Joe into
the passage of time but really we don't
want it to be too much into the passage
we're going to have a Venn diagram
explaining everything and hopefully
there will be yellow school buses
[Laughter]
it's does it I mean does it change the
way you feel about yourself that you're
able to do something like this
well it started very very uh differently
for me I downloaded Tick Tock during the
pandemic like many other very bored uh
Americans amongst other people around
the world and
one of the followers told me that I had
actually sounded like her and I replied
to the video and after that the request
just kept on coming in and given her
content and all the great wonderful
speeches that she's given I haven't run
out of any content yet so no and you
never will peace be upon her we're going
to go out of this with an actual camo a
comma Carmelo whatever cackle just so
our viewers can see how perfect your
imitation is Este thank you so much
thank you and here's here's the real
thing
laughs
even spoke of course with camel Harris
there is no real thing she's doing an
impression of herself but whatever you
see the point pretty good
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight